today is the end of day for it's
Thursday today is the day that I'm
feeling the class sort of catching up to
my general Oh being so today's the day
that has made me empathize a lot with
professors and it's made me think of how
the entire infrastructure of teaching
roles was created in the first place
like it actually doesn't seem very
intuitive to me to to pair a researcher
and an instructor and put it together in
the same role because they're really
different people I'm really sensing a
lot of trepidation and hesitation and
just trying creative ideas which I
completely relate to but it's just so
incredibly striking to me how everyone
has this mentality and not just students
in this class but every single student
I've worked with for science out loud
that you have to measure 20 30 times
before you cut once and that as long as
you measure 20 30 times you only have to
cut once but the the whole paradigm for
this production process is almost the
opposite you measure like three or four
times and you cut 20 times you you right
um you come up with like five ideas and
you write 20 scripts and there's just
this crippling hesitation that's like
overwhelming paralysis to just attempt
to write a script that is so pervasive
through every single student I've worked
with including myself I'm also realizing
that the thing that students need is
concrete examples that people can
recognize big concepts and not be able
to implement them themselves
successfully it takes a lot to become
self aware of your work essentially but
I think today was good because it gave
the students a chance to look at a
script that was written in storyboard it
and sort of unpack what about it works
and what didn't
and sort of tie the bigger concepts that
we've been talking about into a concrete
example the next step that they need to
make is being able to implement that
into their own work so we have the
concepts that we've established we give
examples of what it sort of fit into
those concepts and what don't and then
there needs to be a third level of using
their work specifically to explain if
their work fits into those concepts or
not I feel like each day goes by so
quickly but it's like a massive amount
of time